something here something they've been
working on a long time I don't remember
I know something you don't
I know where you belong you call it
Laurie just got a lot of names and I
know the way
you haven't know what you're saying in
all your life
death is always true hey guys Pete here
are you ready to speculate on where
West's world is going particularly in
Episode four well you're in the right
place cuz it's gonna be a trailer
breakdown you know look at the scene by
scene what they have in there and talk
about exactly where we think things will
be headed before we get to Episode five
which will be the midway point of the
season already so the trailer focuses on
two characters and they do the
voice-over we hear Barnard talk first
and then the men in black Barnard says
there's something here something they've
been working on a long time I don't
remember then the man in black picks up
and he says I know something you don't I
know where you're going you call it
glory but it's got a lot of names and I
know the way you haven't known a true
thing in all your life death is always
true and both of these are pretty
interesting and leave a lot of room for
speculation but let's look at the scene
by scene first and then we'll talk about
it some more the trailer opens with
Bernard which the timeline was pretty
straight forward in the previous episode
so I'm gonna assume that this is
consistent with what we saw in the very
first episode this is when he's in the
bunker with the drone hosts and
Charlotte Hale he has a puzzled look on
his face we see the drone host doing
drone host things droning around I guess
you would call it and let me get these
three guys which lead to what I think is
the most mysterious part of this trailer
they seem to be Dulles employees course
since this is West row we have no idea
if this is something he's seeing in the
present and of course present being when
he's there with Charlotte or if this is
some kind of flashback it looks like we
see them working on the eggs that go
inside the hosts brain and why I think
this is the most mysterious part is
because a some level we're supposed to
believe that all of
this stuff was going on inside the park
without dr. Ford's knowledge I think you
can agree with me that there's really no
chance that that would happen and it
really makes me wonder about how all of
this plays into what happened at the end
of season one either way we see three
Dell O's lab technicians or something
along those lines walk through get
another shot of Barnard next to a drone
host and then we see a couple of shots
of the drones doing their work at first
it looks like we see eyeballs which I
suppose is there to let us know that
they are manufacturing full-on hosts
here not just drone hosts and then we
see the brain egg and the question here
would be is this a normal host brain egg
or is this a different one that is being
manufactured for a different reason
either way it's safe to say that this is
a full-fledged production Center and
they are building hosts here as
mentioned dr. Ford is supposedly not
supposed to know about this or that's
the idea that we're supposed to get
because Bernard didn't know about it but
I don't know I mean they could go a lot
of ways here with this as far as whether
Bernard is remembering being here after
being you know wiped at a time in the
past we're gonna have to wait and see
about that then out of the blue things
take a mysterious turn as we see a drone
host who's standing next to Bernard and
this tech grab the tech by the neck lift
him up against his will obviously and
then apparently throw him into the milk
of course these guys can be hosts - I
don't know why they would have hosts
that look like people and hosts that
look like drones but it is Westworld so
at some point Bernard is in this place
he finds out what's going on and he sees
the drone host throw somebody into the
pull of the printing stuff that they
used to make host with that ends the
Bernard section of the trailer and we go
to the man in black section we see him
with his hands cuffed behind his back
who has him isn't clear here there's
like outlaws not Confed
but I don't recognize anybody let me see
major Craddock who was let go in the
last episode by Teddy looking at a
painting of the crucifixion of Jesus and
there's been a lot of heavy-handed
references to that throughout the season
so far
dolorous seems to have somewhat of a
Messiah Complex
we saw the Last Supper was major
Craddock as the Jesus figure and really
just a bunch of other stuff but here
he's looking at that that this may be
him putting some pieces together in his
own mind Craddock and the other
Confederate owes from the army of new
Virginia are looking for glory they're
looking for a place in their minds
that's called glory and we hear the man
in black refer to that in his voiceover
after that we see the train tracks and
they're using bodies to take the place
of railroad ties I'm not a hundred
percent on how the engineering of that
would work seems a little iffy to me but
it seems to be working fine this is
where he tells them about knowing where
glory is the obvious implication here is
that these two are gonna be teamed up we
see a ride through the desert which I
would guess is these guys going on
horseback there are four shots of kradic
gun then we see him sitting at a table
with whiskey and what looks like
nitroglycerin sitting on top of it and
then we see the man in black coming out
of a house using a host as a shield I
don't think we're supposed to know who
this is I don't think this is supposed
to be an important host but the man in
black is shooting there's people waiting
outside in the rain we see Lawrence
laying on the ground and it looks like
the man in black is able to neutralize
whatever threat it was that was outside
and now he's getting what looks to be a
ceremonial kind of shot glass carried
over to him from a woman the rains
coming down so I don't know if that's
supposed to be rainwater is that's
supposed to be alcohol this did not ring
any bells for me as all I know what's
going on here but like I said it looks
ceremonial in nature it's indication
that
after killing all those people we see
laying around on the ground as she walks
over that somehow or other the man in
black has taken charge and his trip will
continue and it does end with him saying
you haven't known a true thing and all
your life death is always true we know
that that would apply to the man in
black himself in this context because he
believes that he would die if he was
killed here I'm not a hundred percent
sure that that's the case
since he's like the main guy Adela's but
I feel like it's safe to say that he
believes that he could be killed here
that the stakes are real so if he's
saying death is always true what is
actually is he inferring is he using the
resurrections that Craddock saw as some
kind of carrot you know to get Craddock
on his side is he talking to someone
else you guys are gonna have to let me
know what you think there so we don't
see any Dolores Maeve or Charlotte in
this trailer at all but I doubt that
we'll see a whole episode without any
one of those characters I do really
think that the whole Bernard thing is a
little more interesting here out of
these two storylines that they give us
to think about I mean there's a lot of
good and not good theories out there
about Bernard and if you're following
you know what I'm talking about so I
think a lot of us are trying to put
together how he will have his twist in
this season but the man in black is you
know his story is pretty straightforward
he's a human being that's in charge of
this place and he needs to play the game
that dr. Ford laid out for him
of course there could be some serious
twists in that but Mona I think Bernard
is just the bigger mystery right now and
yeah so let me know in the comments what
you guys think are they are those actual
Dulles employees if they're there why
did the drone host throw the one in the
milk is that in the present-day is that
something from the past why do you think
that I mean it's not a lot to go off
here I like the idea that Craddock will
be going with the man in black Lawrence
is still there i hope i really like
lawrence as well that trio seems good to
me it's good to see armistice
back in the last episode and fill out
that roster a little bit more with Maeve
I think they set up a lot with Teddy I
mean obviously they showed Teddy in the
water in the first episode and now
they're showing that he's not blindly
following Dolores as she would have it
but we don't get anything in this
trailer so we can't really speak about
that here so alright the seasons going
good as far as I'm concerned let me know
what you think in the comments make sure
you subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already it's unclear how much
Westworld I'm gonna be able to get done
I'm just gonna do what I can
I mentioned that in the last video so I
won't go into it again here please like
the video tell your friends about it
make sure you follow me on Twitter to
see when I put something new out and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon